Vanessa Bryan is making her first public
remarks since her husband Kobe and
daughter Gianna were killed in a
helicopter crash on Sunday in a very
long Instagram post last night with a
picture of her family
it was very emotional she wrote we are
completely devastated by the sudden loss
or lead national correspondent David
Wagner is outside Staples Center in Los
Angeles David good morning to you as sad
as it was it was really good to hear
from her for the first time yeah it was
Gayle good morning to you I want to show
you the crowd of people that continue to
come here every night to mourn together
as a community last night it was a
mariachi band that played literally
right behind where I am standing for the
first time we are hearing from Vanessa
Bryan she says her grief is really
indescribable but she does intimately
understand what the other families who
lost loved ones are dealing with
she also said in that Instagram post
that she knows Kobe Bryant and her
daughter Gigi both knew that they were
deeply loved Vanessa Bryant unlocked her
private Instagram account sharing
intimate photos of her family including
pictures that showed the close bond
between Kobe Bryant and daughter Gianna
in a statement she said I'm not sure
what our lives hold beyond today and it
is impossible to imagine life without
them but we wake up each day trying to
keep pushing because Kobe and our baby
girl Gigi are shining on us to light the
way Bryant added that the Mamba Sports
Foundation has started a fund to support
the families of those killed in Sunday's
helicopter crash the youngest victims
included 13 year old Gianna and two of
her Mamba sports academy teammates
Payton Chester and Alyssa Altobelli
video from Vanessa Bryan's Instagram
page shows Gianna playing against the
listen using a spin move that her dad
taught Sydney Norwood a seventh grader
says she sometimes train with the three
girls they showed us like skills and
stuff and it was like really sweet to
have people like older giving us advice
and stuff Kobe Bryant's own former team
the Los Angeles Lakers returned to
practice Wednesday for the first time
since Bryant died the players are
expected to face off again
the Portland Trailblazers tomorrow we
want to represent what Kobe was about
you know more than anything we've always
wanted to make him proud the wreckage of
that helicopter has been taken from here
from California and transported to
Arizona for analysis Gail just last
night the LA County coroner's office put
out a final update saying that they have
positively identified all nine victims
they use DNA and fingerprint technology
to do that the cause of death has been
who what forced trauma the manner has
been certified as an accident it's so
tough to hear thank you David it was
really lovely to hear Vanessa Bryant
also acknowledge the other families who
were going through this undescribable
unthinkable grief yes no no it was that
that post when it appeared it was it was
it was very nice to hear from but it was
in some ways it was comforting to see it
too yes hero was good to hear from her
we're all thinking her and her kids